this is the College of Fine Arts which
offers conservatory style programs in
five distinct colleges architecture art
design drama and music the College of
Fine Arts Building was designed by
architect Henry horn Boston who was the
first Dean of the College of Fine Arts
and also the architect of many of the
original buildings on campus horn basta
was designed called for a beautiful
mural in the entryway of this building
so that the students would be inspired
as they came in and out it was at horn
Boston's insistence that st. Peter's
Basilica in Rome be placed in the direct
center of the mural because he thought
it was the pinnacle of man's
architectural achievement and he liked
that building so much he had its floor
plan inlaid in the marble floors beneath
it the largest part of the mural
directly above the doorway is Hell's
Gate Bridge in New York City another
structure designed by horn basta land
also the first bridge completed entirely
out of Carnegie steel this room is the
Alumni Concert Hall one of the main
performance spaces for the School of
Music which is housed primarily in this
building along with the School of Art
and the School of Architecture we're
backstage of Kresge Theatre in what was
called the green room which is famous
for having its walls signed by graduates
of the School of Drama
however feeling rebellious Oscar
award-winning actress Holly Hunter
decided to sign the wall while she was
still an underclassmen
you